[Musique]
bienvenue pour ce paris saclay
exceptionnel c'est le printemps c'est
paris saclay spring deuxième édition de
ce grand rendez vous international de
l'innovation votre territoire met en
avant l'excellence scientifique et
technologique mais dean saclay tous les
acteurs de l'innovation de la recherche
de la science et du développement sont
réunis ici à centrale supélec
il y a cinq grands thèmes cinq villages
innovation impute conteste des qui note
une table ronde internationale et même
des visites inédites de grands centres
de recherche et de développement privées
voilà c'est tout ça paris sat l'extrait
[Musique]
m
sans plus attendre je retrouve donc
celui qui est à l'origine de ce paris
saclay spring à savoir philippe van de
maele bonjour bonjour vous êtes le
directeur général le pea paris saclay et
alors il ya une forme ou que vous
employez que je trouve assez judicieux
c'est cet événement ce pour maximiser
mes possibles de l'innovation expliquez
moi oui absolument l'idée est notre rôle
a loupé à paris saclay c'est
d'accompagner le développement de ce
cluster et l'innovation c'est beaucoup
lié à des proximités à des rencontres
même parfois des rencontres improbables
de gens qui à priori ne seraient pas
rencontrés et c'est comme ça que se
cristallisent permettent de créer
l'innovation économique dire qu'on a de
la recherche
il faut passer ensuite l'activité
économique effectivement notre rôle par
différents axes dont cet événement qui
est un événement majeur c'est de
maximiser les possibles de ces
innovations
c'est vraiment vraiment ça en permettant
les rencontres où il ya les rencontres
un lieu de rencontre on le voit bien
même ici on voit qu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de personnes qui y participent
d'ailleurs vous avez 2400 inscrit
absolument c'est le double dernier on
était 1200 participants et cette année
de la deuxième édition on est à 2400
donc j'espère que ça va doubler comme ça
d'année en année mais en tout cas c'est
le témoignage que cet écosystème
transforme prend vie attire et que les
gens ont compris toutes les
potentialités du territoire mais l'année
dernière on était très fortement centrée
sur la partie académique les centres de
recherche publics et puis les start up
et il nous paraissait essentiel dans cet
écosystème
le rôle des grands groupes et dont
notamment de tous les centres de
recherche des grands groupes ils sont
très nombreux sur paris saclay parce
qu'on a quand même 15 % de toutes les
recherches privées qui est française qui
seront sur ce territoire là c'est un
rôle important pour accompagner des
start up pour faire des partenariats
avec les avec les laboratoires de
l'université de paris saclay pour créer
ces liens et c'est important que les
grands groupes qui au delà de venir vers
implanter leurs centres de recherche qui
est en cours puisque des revenus secret
là servier va construction bâtiment donc
et cette dynamique là participent à ce
type d'événement et c'est essentiel
qu'on crée aussi ce lien avec l'économie
existantes et notamment les grands
causses et bongo plus accès
aussi à l'occasion de ce paris saclay
spring d'ouvrir les portes de leurs
centres de recherche et ça c'est quand
même absolument temps et c'est très
important ça montre aussi justement leur
volonté de participer à cette innovation
de la grande île nous ouvre les portes
des centres de recherche avec des
conditions parce que effectivement il ya
un nombre de secrets dedans donc c'est
important et on a notamment airbus
dassault qui ont ouvert leurs portes
pour pouvoir permettre à des gens
deux rencontres et travailler sur leurs
recherches à eux et d'ouvrir le
territoire et aussi de symboliser que
l'ensemble du territoire des trois
agglomérations un versailles grand parc
saint quentin en yvelines
et puis paris saclay en essonne
travaille collectivement dans cette
dynamique globale avec le monde
universitaire et les entreprises
on va parler d'innovation de recherche
de technologie mais il ya aussi un
spring market alors là oui pourquoi
absolument pas ce que ce territoire ce
cluster s'inscrit vraiment dans un
territoire existants avec des
productions locales notamment des
productions agricoles et donc on a voulu
proposer aux agriculteurs locaux devenir
aussi participé à ce prix ça fait partie
aussi de ce lien territorial du
développement durable merci 22 mali
l'entreprise marque est aussi la période
de reprendre des forces car il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de choses de me
prévenir qu'on vous souhaite une très
bonne édition de paris saclay merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
c'est l'une des grandes nouveautés de
cette seconde édition de paris saclay
spring les grands groupes sont
partenaires de l'événement on retrouve
total edf servier et bien d'autres alors
pourquoi ont-ils décidé de se lancer
dans cette aventure et bien je vais leur
poser la question là nous sommes au
village mobilité c'est l'un des cinq
villages innovation de paris saclay
spring et je me trouve avec françois
moulleau bonjour bonjour vous êtes
directeur de la communication pour
l'ensemble de la r&d d'edf et bien sûr
vous êtes très implantés sur le
territoire
alors pourquoi vous avez décidé vous en
tant qu edf de participer à cet
événement l'écouté comme vous venez de
le signaler
c'est dans la droite ligne de notre
implantation nous sommes donc depuis
trois ans sur le plateau de saclay dans
le quartier de l'école polytechnique
parce que nous sommes une r&d de
partenariat nous avons des accords avec
tous les grandes institutions
académiques et grandes écoles de ce
plateau sur des questions aussi bien sur
la mobilité sur l'internet des objets
sur le vieillissement des matériaux sur
les réseaux intelligents du fameux ce
mardi donc nous sommes au coeur des
partenariats du plateau donc il était
tout à fait logique pour nous que nous
soyons un acteur majeur de ce grand
évènement l'innovation qui exprime sa
coiffe donc spring saclay c'est
l'archétype de l'effet plateau ce que
j'appelle l'effet plateau c'est à dire
le fait qu'on puisse mettre ensemble et
se faire rencontrer a priori des gens
qui n'avaient pas grand chose à voir
donc vous êtes consorts de ce village
mobilité qu'est ce que vous allez
montrer qu est ce que vous montrez aux
montres différents éléments on montre
d'une part ce qu'on fait en matière de
recharge électrique vous savez les
nouvelles bornes de recharge les
recharge intelligente 1 qui paieront
aussi de rendre de l'électricité au
réseau lorsqu'il y aura il y aura besoin
nous sommes aussi présents sur
l'hydrogène edf vient de lancer une
nouvelle filiale qui semble dynamique
de l'hydrogène décarbonés céder sans
production de co2 à base d'électrolysé
de l'eau et donc évidemment ina mix qui
a été lancé tout récemment est présent
sur ce sur ce stand
merci beaucoup françois mollo mais alors
bon spring autres partenaires de paris
saclay spring autre point de vue nous
sommes dans le village de santé avec
christophe thuriau bonjour bonjour vous
êtes directeur général du centre de
recherche servier savait tout n'est pas
encore présent sur le territoire mais
qui arrive très vite en fait absolument
nous avons commencé à construire enfin
plus ou moins à creuser pour l'instant
et nous travaillons nous installer au
cours de l'exercice 21-22 donc dans nos
patients faisant à présent sur le
plateau
alors pourquoi pour participer pour se
lancer dans cette aventure de paris
saclay à ce prénom parce que c'est
important de présenter notre futur
centre de recherche qui est pour nous et
est un investissement majeur à la fois
effectivement pour notre recherche mais
aussi dans l'écosystème de recherche en
france et nous pensons que le cluster
paris saclay et l'endroit où il faut
être
et c'est important donc d'avoir des
événements comme celui-ci parce que nous
voulons par notre présence dans le
cluster paris saclay
c'est vraiment installer notre campus
notre campus dans le campus et c'est ce
concept que l'on que l'on développe une
des caractéristiques du cluster
paris-saclay c'est le mariage de
sciences expérimentales comme la
biologie et puis des sciences plus dur
et pour développer de nouvelles
solutions thérapeutiques demain on a
besoin d'énormément de compétences il ya
beaucoup d'écoles ici qui vont fournir
les expertises dont on aura besoin dans
le futur donc c'est bon ça voilà vous
avez peut-être à contrer l'ordre
vos futurs collaborateurs et futurs
collaboratrice merci avec nous
[Musique]
total faisait partie des partenaires
donc de ceux de cet événement de paris
saclay spring total qui vient tout juste
d'arriver sur le plateau
bonjour nathalie brunel vous êtes
bonjour vous êtes directrice du projet
total saclay justement dans cette lettre
depuis combien de temps à trois mois à
peine si ça et bien en fait la direction
recherche et développement du groupe a
déménagé il ya exactement trois mois et
est arrivé donc sur le plateau de saclay
pour commencer cette aventure en fait
une aventure qui a démarré il ya une
dizaine d'années sur le photovoltaïque
avec une petite équipe et donc on voit
que progressivement on grossit jusqu'à
l'implantation d'un nouveau centre
d'innovation et de recherche pour le
groupe que l'on prévoit à l'horizon 2022
mais là pourquoi participer à à paris
saclay spring qu'est ce qui vous a donné
envie d'être là déjà là en fait on est
déjà présent voilà si nous sommes là
sinon rien fait ce premier déménagement
avant même d'avoir notre propre toit
c'est pour commencer cette aventure de
rencontres et de co construction puisque
nous notre ambition ici c'est traiter
des thématiques dirait une nouvelle on
va avoir deux grands axes thématiques
qui sont l'un sur les énergies bas
carbone et puis également l' axe du
numérique et donc comme c'est des
thématiques en plein développement
on veut vraiment les co construire avec
les acteurs d'excellence de l'écosystème
on veut avoir des partenariats et donc
pour nous et ses contacts pour
construire il faut on a pensé qu'il
fallait déjà être ici est commencé de
quoi vous êtes convaincus par paris
saclay springs reviendrai l'année
prochaine avec un stand avec des
propositions avec alors on effectivement
convaincu des présents dans ce type
d'événement
ce que j'espère c'est qu'on sera encore
plus nombreux du groupe avenir moi je
vais faire effectivement la publicité
auprès de mes collègues parce qu'il ya
tellement avoir tellement à partager que
cette dynamique de rencontres
effectivement il ya un côté virale et
donc il faut que ça se poursuive oui
sous quelle forme on a un an pour y
réfléchir
il ya un merci beaucoup et nathalie
whannell d'avoir répondu à la question
merci
me voici à présent et que patricia villa
slada bonjour bonjour vous êtes
directrice de transdev système de
transport autonome et on voit ici à ce
stand 1,9 d'être présent à de nombreux
endroits de paris saclay ce prix
pourquoi avoir accepté de participer
donc nous faisons partie du projet paris
saclay autonome aux slaves qui est un
gros projet dé cet événement au sprint
donc c'est un projet d'expérimentation
de véhicules autonomes sur le territoire
n'est par exemple et donc ce véhicule
par exemple va circuler sur le
territoire
celui qu'on voit derrière nous oui nous
nous faisons déjà des tests journée la
nuit et le service donc on va lui ouvrir
progressivement au public ses liaisons
nocturne entre la gare de massy et le
plateau de saclay avec quatre arrêts
intermédiaires
alors vous qui avez participé à de
nombreux événements en quoi celui-ci est
il important
il va céder 6 et sur l'innovation et
limbé de salaire dans les années à venir
c'est la mobilité autonome c'est un
talent autant sur le plan technologique
que sur les plans nécessaires dont on
parle un peu moins mais tout aussi
important c'est dépenser la mobilité des
déments les véhicules autonomes ou
l'utilisation de véhicules hautement ça
va être très probablement plus que
remplaçant véhicule conduit par un
véhicule autonome il faut repenser
comment ces véhicules autonomes offres
de services complémentaires c'est ce
qu'on fait ici sur ce territoire c'est
un complément des services la nuit quand
les bus sont à l'arrêt les bus conduit
et puis les eaux et cadres c'est un
service complémentaire
là où il y en a pas graphiquement il y
en a pas ils circulent deux jours mais
c'est dans une zone
ce sera dans le campus de polytechnique
où il n'ya pas des services aujourd'hui
et va merci beaucoup merci bon paris sa
que le string merci aux quelques temps
forts de paris saclay ce prix le pitch
conteste en fait là juste derrière moi
vingt-cinq start up du territoire sont
en train de défendre leur projet et
elles ont peu de temps christophe pineau
agents que quatre minutes sont quatre
minutes pour pour présenter leur leur
business model look technologie la façon
dont ils vont aller sur le marché est de
convaincre un jury constitué de
l'investisseur et d'industriels qui
seront qui se réuniront ensuite dans une
petite salle pour délibérer et faire un
choix sur ce qui sera le plus cohérent
le qui leur semblera le plus cohérent
entre le business model la technologie
le lien avec le territoire qui l'intérêt
en fait pour tout ces start-up de
participer à cet événement et surtout de
leur portée alors le premier intérêt
c'est d'abord d'être visible visible des
investisseurs parce qu'ils viennent
chercher pour la plupart ils viennent
chercher des fonds et ouvrir leur
capital mais aussi des industriels qui
vont leur permettre peut-être demain de
pouvoir faire des essais de fer d'époque
et puis et puis peut-être de trouver des
clients aussi parce que c'est quand même
le but d'une entreprise c'est d'avoir
des clients et de gagner de l'argent
avec ces produits
alors je est important on l'a compris
est ce que vous avez déjà été convaincu
par les projets ce qu'on est vraiment
dans du très haut niveau
ah oui les projets ont été sélectionnés
ils sont d'abord issu
principalement du territoire paris
saclay qui est un territoire par nature
constitué de beaucoup d'ingénieurs de
beaucoup de recherche et donc oui cdc
souvent des projets de haut niveau avec
avec des niveaux de technicité important
merci à sa fille dont on va vous laisser
retourner avec jury mais là c'est encore
au revoir on le savait le prestigieux
classement du m&a et il a confirmé paris
saclay fait partie des huit kloster
mondiaux de l'innovation et paris saclay
spring a permis donc d'échanger entre
ses différents pôles avec une table
ronde internationale vraiment l'objectif
c'était de confronter les différents
points de vue les visions des uns des
autres sur les grands enjeux de
l'innovation technologique et de
l'investissement george akerlof bonjour
bonjour vous avez fait partie de cette
table ronde il y avait des personnes qui
venaient de l'ombre de chine du japon de
paris saclay évidemment vous mais de
boston qu'est ce que vous en avez retenu
de cette table ronde lancer une table
ronde qui je crois a bien montré
l'importance d'un cluster tels que celui
de paris saclay à la dynamique que l'on
voit dans ces clusters est importante
elle a besoin d'eux
de l'aspect académique donc les grandes
écoles les universités qu'on voit sur le
plateau mais aussi des entreprises des
jeunes entreprises des grandes
entreprises
et tout ça ça suffit pas et il ya le
liant en plus qui est l'effet cluster
que sont ces conférences et cette table
ronde ont été quelque part un exemple
très bien même merci beaucoup jean
jacques est un plaisir et bienvenue à
boston
paris saclay springs est terminé on se
donne rendez vous l'année prochaine pour
une troisième édition qui sera sans nul
doute aussi réussi on espère vraiment
vous avoir fait partager cette journée
dédiée à l'innovation à la technologie à
l'excellence de votre territoire
on se donne rendez vous pour un prochain
numéro de paris-saclay tv bien sûr et
d'ici là restez informé sur notre site
le pap est ce point fr mais aussi sur tv
78 bien sûr
[Musique]